hold the pickles gang little tour update
Vermont in Connecticut we added second
shows of both of those cities come out
and see the boys yeah get the tickets
before they're sold out we got uh
Connecticut Vermont and then we're going
down to Florida baby Tampa second show
added limited tickets left on that then
we're in Dania Beach Florida we're going
to Raleigh North Carolina Louisville
Kentucky Cleveland Ohio Columbus Ohio
more cities coming soon get those
Dickies gang let's party welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're good to be
classy or to just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here in hoodies and New Edition baby
living high on the hog having a good
time you ain't lying baby she's down at
the VFW trying to land herself a man
with some bennies as she says okay my
co-host is coming at me from right next
coming at me coming at you right next to
me he is the CEO of are you garbage he's
an international businessman let me tell
you something right now I don't care who
knows it he's my best goddamn pal in the
whole wide world and I love him give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
iTunes full video of album YouTube as
you know those numbers are cooking
[Laughter]
where do we get this
[Applause]
I got a monologue then obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com check it the [__] out
gang it's a party over there yeah and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
works the twos the threes and the fours
crosses the t's and dots the eyes now
you can get a little peek at them ladies
give it up for T-Bone McGruff and stoby
McMullen what up dudes yo listen there
are dudes and then there are all-time
dudes yeah the guy we got in here is a
[__] all-time dude man
getting the long hair ain't the [__]
lying we got some real talent in the
[__] building right now
you're doing this on purpose
not a fan of the program
ah gang I don't know what to say about
this young man you can see him just
about [__] everywhere he is a [__]
force of nature of course he is the
co-host of Matt and Shane's secret
podcast and you can see him just about
everywhere else if you're trying to get
tickets for his show good [__] luck
because the kid sells out yeah give it
up for Shane Gillis hey
[Laughter]
and just a cold stare over your shoulder
I can feel the wedgie creeping up my ass
now you guys that's great you guys are
good at that I can't do that that's why
I make fun of it
you know when you suck at something
you're like man yeah [__] dorks yeah
how do you feel about guys that dance at
weddings
I don't know if I hate anyone more dudes
that seriously dance do you wish you
could dance though no I'm [__] nice
will you dance at a wedding oh yeah you
win sober you got to be drunk you gotta
have a couple in yeah it's got to be at
the end yeah guys mopping I wake up and
go did I [__] dance like a [__]
lady
[Laughter]
it's a girl thing there's got to be
enough people on the floor to blend in
yeah be honest do you know any dances
could you do the Macarena
I mean I could do yeah I think can you
do the Electric Slide
[Laughter]
oh man that's about it your dad just
sitting in the corner staring at you
[__] chase [__] bad enough he
ordered the fish have you ever seen your
dad dance uh yeah fast answer slow dance
he doesn't move too much
it's a white guy dance it's arms yeah I
don't know if he asked it is you ever
see your pop tuning anybody up uh no
I've never seen him fight never no you
ever see him try to fight yeah
I saw him you got he got a fight at a
high school game sure yeah yours yeah uh
football game
in the stands I saw him and my other my
friend Jamal's dad got into a fight was
he Josh no they teamed up they joined
forces they joined forces
style coal region trash
yeah
yeah it was fully Lethal Weapon
yeah I'm too old for this [__] yeah I
imagine those games were pretty intense
that Shamokin was yeah yeah were you the
only one in your in your class that got
D1 offers uh no you probably had some
hitters yeah he played quarterback he
was nice really yeah he went to
Millersville he ended up setting like
every receiving record no [__] yeah it's
pretty funny yeah that's all right yeah
that's good stuff
shout out to Jamal Smith
you know him you love them all right
listen it's been a while since you've
been here thank you for coming and
sitting down with us and sincerely buddy
you know how much we love you
congratulations everything that you're
doing we're it's we it's unbelievable I
wish we go back to the World Series dude
that was we were just briefly talking
about it some of the that was the
wildest week so fun that was [__]
insane I think we ended up at a VIP area
with Freddie Mitchell yeah oh yeah and
Freddie goes who's paying for this what
are you talking about it's like I want
you guys know I got that bucket of beers
for you guys it's free
why are you doing that he was whipping
with the color guard
yeah he had like ROTC people dancing on
them a couple Coast Guard chicks
yeah it was all right Freddy was going
for the one that was nice it was a good
time I don't know if he's married or
nothing
respect he was yeah he wasn't going at
it there's no twerking involved no I was
also one of my favorite things you
turned to Foley and go I'll give you 100
bucks if you get on the mechanical bull
dude I would have given you so much
what's this
and he [__] fell he tried to jump so
the guy had to help him to get up yeah
so he was [__] that the the guy who was
running it was on the other side of the
bull and he tried to like pull him up
over it he did it he pulled him too hard
Bear Went Over and just smashed him he
just landed right on him yeah it was
wonderful O'Connor did it that O'Connor
loves him again and didn't break eye
contact with us he's got the hit moves
man yeah he loves that [__] that's
something there Dirty Dancing over there
he loves getting it on so many
Mechanicals
he's gonna get one for the yard I saw
him at uh Mohegan Sun that's a big one
yeah yeah that's like the lobby it was
it was right after I got fired from SNL
and everyone was like you're gonna be
fine dude you're watching him 20 people
in a casino in Connecticut I bombed and
then got drunk and watched O'Connor and
Beezer on a [__] mechanical bullet
that is a roughly [__] dude
I think Eddie Murphy was on that night I
was like God damn it
could have been at the after party
ing on the [__] he's good at it I'm
just sitting there like hell yeah he is
unironically good at riding a mechanical
they try to toss him and he just like
[__] gyrates with it
just anyway congrats thanks yeah you're
[__] killing it but we haven't had
you on in a while so we want to do a
little recap you know obviously things
are a little bit different
um I'm gonna do a little recap on you
here all right a couple of things who's
cutting your hair Tommy
what are you doing that's Amish [__]
dude get the [__] out I go downstairs
you are [__] you are meeting potatoes
do you tip them no nothing no just say
come down give me a trim yeah I said I
need a haircut he's tough to get a hold
of guys even though he's downstairs he's
doing nothing I'm like dude help because
I have nowhere to go in my neighborhood
I tried it once I got a [__]
Dominican
that's been a thing for me I live in a
Dominican neighborhood and there's
nothing they tape you up you look like
you look like the world's worst
undercover cop that's crazy they oiled
my hair when I got done the guy oiled it
straight down it was it was the day
before I filmed that special and I like
had like a weird panic attack I was like
I need a haircut he's walking out with a
Caesar
I couldn't believe it I I didn't need a
haircut either I'm lining your eyes so
nervous I was like I should get a
haircut got shaved my head and then
flattened the front with oil I thought I
was like holy [__] put a wave what have
I done yeah dude a bad haircut will
[__] ruin your week I just rolled a
dice in Virginia Beach I just needed one
we were on the road and I got like looks
nice thank you and it was this like 88
year old woman just [__] [__]
handshaking with the scissors [__]
scared the [__] out of me
um are you treating yourself at all I
know you're an old school guy
uh I know you gotta take Ubers
I don't take the train
GrubHub
console it should be taking a helicopter
yeah
I take Uber pulls after spots
[Laughter]
what about like a nice dinner or
something like that you wouldn't boys on
the road sometimes yeah yeah what's out
looking like a steakhouse or something
sometimes if there is yeah and you pick
up the bill I presume yes where would
you go growing up where would you where
would like your pop take you guys to
like a family dinner would you hit a
Friday
no is that a chain
Jesus dude horses there it's like a yeah
it's not great there's goats out back
you get the baddest bed and goats out
back and there's uh does that have a
Michelin star what are we talking here
it's so bad when I was a kid I thought
it was the nicest coach is a kid get a
runny Beard award ghost rules and then
we would have uh there's mints on the
way out and we would all get handfuls
and throw them at each other on the way
it was a tradition Min flight in the
parking lot on the way out
uh you are a PA boy are you hot dog
people I'm not you're not yeah the
family
felt my dad will
[__] destroy grab some dogs
unbelievable put down some diesels all
right we'll be like all right we're
gonna you know there's nieces and
nephews so they come over and he like
grills burgers and dogs okay he makes 30
[__] hot dogs and eats he eats them
all dude sweet is that this weekend in
Austin dude I mean I ate about 18 hot
dogs on Saturday really you guys are hot
dog guys huge yeah you're a PA guy you
know how you know that I've always hated
hot dogs
really yeah Coney Island dogs and
Scranton I know just Abe's in
Wilkes-Barre nothing nothing oh [__] no
it's a burger guy okay not that there's
a you know it's one of those arguments
what the burger where people yeah where
it's like
I like both yeah yeah
it would be the burger but I'm I'm trash
I love the glove a good hot dog uh I got
one if you go out to eat you get a
burger right and you take a bite do you
put it back down straight or do you flip
it over
I'm gonna have to start flipping yeah
I've been eating soggy Burgers decades
exactly getting the [__] games no no
yeah I just ate two slices of pizza out
on the street right yeah
I love dollars dude I love it yeah I
[__] best in New York man [__]
love a good dollar slice huh how often
are you washing the hair
how often do I like actually putting
shampoo yeah yeah every day and what's
kind of soap are you using
uh there's some Dove soap in there yeah
yeah man you are old school I tell you
that why you should be using something
fancy something nice yeah little Keels
or something I was using hand soap for a
while
so I'm living high on the hog now dude I
didn't buy any soap and I just took it
off the sink
yeah well [__] it it works
good
[Laughter]
I think that's normal no it's not what
the dial pump you're in there
yeah I got one have you used soap on
your past your dick past my dick on the
way down I'll like what do you mean on
your life typically gravity does most of
the work nothing's touching my legs yeah
you don't wash your legs barely I'm I'm
kind of in that world as well for sure
every now and then I'll get up [__]
though I've been getting my ass a lot
the older you get I got you just hand
straight hand to it I'll do yeah I'll
get in there I gotta go in there
it's like sweeping a village in Vietnam
I got I gotta [__] go away
[Laughter]
[Music]
what about a vacation
I don't know if you've ever taken a
vacation
yeah I went to Florida two years ago
okay uh strictly vacation no shows no
shows that was it that's pretty good
where in Florida uh it was on the gulf
it was like outside of Panama is that it
Panama City is that on the I don't know
I don't know on the gulf I forget I know
Camp is on the gulf Scene It was up it
was up by Alabama it was on the not even
the knife
Alabama it's so nice it's the best what
about like Europe you don't want to take
take a trip to I've been there I've
lived in I lived in Spain for like six
months [__] that's what I wanted to talk
to you yeah what the [__] was that you
were a student you were a teacher yeah I
thought I was I was selling cars in
Mechanicsburg and I was like
had you had a degree did you yeah you
got in Spanish no I was just a history
degree but where did you get why did you
end up getting your degree from
Westchester you went to Western that's
where you went for four years yeah you
lived there yeah at Westchester yeah it
was [__] awesome and then he got out
of that and then you started teaching in
Spain I sold cars and then I went and
taught in Spain yeah
for like six months it was great where
in Spain uh Madrid okay north north of
the city it was great yes up in some
shitty Village called elvion
how's your Spanish yeah terrible now to
replay
wait was it good at the time yeah really
especially you get drunk there's no
inhibition Let it Fly using the accent
it's fun I was dude
I was just talking about this last night
with someone I I went there thinking
like all right I'll be cultured you know
what I mean I literally I went to the
same bar every day oh dude yeah got
shit-faced every day in the same bar I
didn't see anything yeah I didn't go
anywhere we did that in Dublin went over
to see my buddies were living over there
for school and we didn't do didn't see
it went to the same Casino every day
crazy and then just we just got blind
drunk yeah it's [__] straight up the
middle but it's like that's what you
like doing why don't you just do it
that's what I'm saying it's like I'm you
know what it is no but occasionally I'll
do something and I'll be like oh that's
not worth it this is nice do a nice trip
I went to museums that I was sick there
you go yeah
you think you want to spend a couple of
weeks in Italy up in [__] I think I
am yeah
yeah that would be [__] sick [__]
shout out there they just got a little
trouble actually a little no like today
bootlegged movies
yeah it was a little worse than that
there was 600 bootleg uh accusers came
forward
they put like 600 new movies these
[__] lying kids
I'm gonna keep lying
Bootlegger bootlegs keep lying about my
kids I'm trying to enjoy the assisting
Chapel over here yeah like protesters
outside uh have you ever been to a free
concert
but like a radio still like a no okay
like a wmgk all right okay you haven't
thrown out the first pitch anywhere yet
have you no all right we're working on
dropping the puck at the AHL game that'd
be awesome you gotta throw out the first
Phantoms no who buyers yeah the Bears
it's you [__] dude that's my
hometown you guys stay with the fans
don't [__]
you're not welcome in the Giant Center
State of the fan the friendly confines
at the Giant Center how do you feel
about the rotisserie chicken Shane and
when was the last time you had one I was
speaking your language shout out to the
Roto guys I don't know when the last
time I had one was okay recent yeah
within the last two months you doing the
whole thing what's that eating the whole
thing yeah crushing it uh yeah saved
one's tough yeah
oh forget it yeah of course no there's a
place right by my house grocery store
yeah eight bucks or something I don't
know exactly what you're talking about
no no sides yeah straight hot sauce
no utensils
um are you in the living room are you
eating uh at the coffee table or are you
do you eat in the in like the kitchen uh
I have a table right
yeah I sit at the table you do I mix it
up you'll sit at that table Yeah like
you can watch TV okay you watch TV from
the from the dining room Fox News That's
dad [__] dude Fox News
you're sitting at the table watching TV
look at them they're trying to arrest
him
so Witch Hunt dude I was talking about
mom yesterday like what are you watching
he's like I'm watching the five
yeah five sticks crazy he loves it the
five's tough yeah yeah
I watched the five man
she was wrapped up in that now that
whole thing I was yeah I was watching it
I watched I watched him fly in really I
was watching the plane I saw the takeoff
yeah that is a pretty dope place all
right it looks like a joke how cool it
is yeah yeah he landed in a trump plane
and then shut down the city drove
through in a giant motorcade it's like
come on man
that's my president y'all quick mugshots
and Prince back to [__] Miami Heat
mugs if that mug shot gets released I
don't think they took it right I thought
it said no mugs yeah oh really yeah damn
it dude how much power you got to skirt
a mug shot they get everybody
not him [__] Nick Nolte's is a tough
luck Nick Nolte's I think I'm nice to
Trump [__] mugshot t-shirt would be
yeah
he would have made so much money and
that's pretty good missed opportunity on
the merch yeah uh do you have a mug shot
he is a merch King no I don't I don't no
no do you have one no yeah me neither
never been collared no yeah I only got
like under ages yeah right that's right
they don't mugshot they don't yeah we
got busted they didn't even arrest me
yeah they didn't arrest us either yeah
busted at a party drinking and they just
made our parents come get us yeah that
was it so scary so scary oh yeah you
think you were getting sent the [__]
federal prison
you're a senior in high school crying
your girlfriend's there dad's gonna kill
me that's a bad law my dad's gonna be
drunk he's gonna beat my ass can't even
come pick you up he's [__] up camera
talk about Lucy Lucy Lucy sweet little
lucy let's talk about them new Lucy
Breakers that's what I want to get into
it's like the adult version of finding a
toy inside the cereal box which they
don't give you good ones anymore but
Lucy does it's a nicotine pouch with a
little surprise inside Lucy Breakers
they got little tiny capsules in there I
heard that they unleash delicious
flavors we're talking mint mango Berry
and my favorite espresso you pop one in
you're on the move there you're doing
your thing I love them I love the
expression espresso ones because I'm a
dirtbag that's why I say espresso proven
to be there ain't an X in there you get
cappuccino uh guys uh for 15 off your
Breakers check out their uh check out
their subscribe and save options uh they
will give you a little surprise when
life is feels overwhelming you deserve
it baby visit lucy.co that's
l-u-c-y-.co use the promo code garbage
to get 20 off your first order baby
they're giving it away over there there
you go shipping is always free because I
are good guys that's Lucy dot
c-o-l-u-c-y dot Co promo code garbage
will receive 20 off and always free
shipping here comes a fine print baby
Lucy products are for adults of legal
age and every order is age verified this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical do it okay let's talk
about this plate oh baby you mean the
best posters in a Biz yeah if you're
still decorating your your walls with
paper posters you're what we call them
the business of those yeah we're putting
black light posters on your wall like
some like some Stoner teenager do
yourself a favor gang Tech check out
this plate they're absolutely fantastic
metal posters that you can hang up in
about 20 seconds in seconds it's easy
peasy they're perfect for renters they
can't put holes in the wall now listen
we're all renters out there okay not a
lot of landowners listening so if you're
renting they deck your place out you
know what I mean who doesn't like a nice
punch in the wall you can cover up on a
display it's a good time plus they got
good licensing deals that's what it's
all about these days yeah they got the
license and things deal they got the
connections they got Mandalorian
Jurassic Park South Park I love all the
Avengers stuff myself yeah uh we got
Seinfeld ones uh they're fantastic you
click the link in our description to see
some of our favorite this place and save
up to 34 you get 20 off when you buy one
or two and 34 off when you buy three or
more discounts will automatically be
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use the code Garbage
g-a-r-b-a-g-e When you visit display.com
that's display.com code garbage or click
the link in the show notes do it baby
how do you feel about the deviled egg uh
I've come around yeah when I was a young
man I thought they were disgusting
really yeah were you a pick eater as a
kid fan uh yeah yeah I was are you a
pick eater now do you think no not
really although I don't like like
mushrooms I'm not a mushroom an onion
there's a lot of stuff at all
like mushrooms onions tomatoes hold the
[__] on you don't like onions you don't
like mushrooms no I like I like carrots
that's a fun joke I don't like carrots
not what I'm saying psych yeah what
about sushi we eat sushi really basic
Sushi though I don't like the wild [__]
I don't know like the eel sure but
you'll do raw tuna you'll do raw salmon
yeah all right yeah how about raw
oysters no I don't like oysters how do
you get to stay cooked
medium rare
gentlemen all right all right not bad
yeah what do you order when you do go to
a steakhouse do you have a you have a
cut that you like filet mignon you go
filet it's a European
little filet mignon okay foreign
I learned porterhouse Tim Dillon
schooled me on porterhouse but that's
all I know I don't know one of them
porterhouse is filet in the strip you
should start doing the porterhouse okay
with the squad I don't know any of them
yeah you go in to Tim you however many
people are you going I'll have the
porterhouse for four or whatever it is
and that's the filet in the strip I
don't even know what the other side is
you taking anything home with you from
the restaurant take a little leftovers
no never ever hmm
yeah I can't take it home no I feel like
a poor person even though I just
typically poor when I was doing it but
yeah no I just eat it yeah if I don't
like it then I'm going I'm not going to
tell you the whole thing yeah exactly
I'm 100 I'm if I'm at a table it's I'm
finishing the plate 100 really almost
nothing to take home every single time
you getting dessert no never I cannot
see you something for the table five
honors dude
it actually bothers me when someone does
order dessert it is I I bet you Connie
likes a little Strawberry Shortcake of
course he does that's [__] yeah in his
triple chocolate cake then you take a
bite you go I don't wanna someone goes
here try it
that's [__] good yeah it's all right
yeah
um please you ever listen to The
Sopranos theme in the car
no doubt I've done that several times
bumping that's a good time
that's all right okay
that would get into it [__] that's yeah
never even thought about it just
unironically a montage of me just
there's a goddamn hit I don't know what
to tell you uh have you ever owned a
copy of The Boondock Saints
definitely yeah do you have any DVDs now
no nothing actually no
you have your Playstation or Xbox yeah
do you have the actual games or you do
it all online just download them now all
right
um
Boondock Saints though I remember that
was that was big in my family like I
remember Irish my uncles were talking
about they're like it's an incredible I
dressed up like them for Halloween one
year ago
both of them yeah
it was not my fire did anybody get it no
uh it's a cold classic I was like
selling it dude that movie did not age
well oh yeah it's bad yeah it's tough I
saw it a handful of years ago it wasn't
great yeah huh any Crystal Light in the
house growing up
no what would you have for dinner if if
your mom made milk milk yeah every time
I was home [__]
[__] drinking iced tea one season
didn't touch the field
got dominated every day uh I was home
like two weeks ago my dad for lunch was
eating a tuna wrap with milk that's
crazy middle of the day I was like Jesus
tuna and dairy milk dude I don't know
what it is dads have something I would
have for lunch
that's crazy it is dude but I'll say
this man dads know how to make tuna
salad like a [__] Michelin star Chef
they just do it [__] nice right
amount of salt how many deads
have you seen do this
putting yours
we threw down yeah my dad used to hook
up tuna salad put a little Relish in it
[__] be so jealous a little black
pepper make it nice my dad would eat
cottage cheese love it out of the can
love it is that normal I don't know
I love it do you eat cottage cheese at
all dude I love it he just would spoon
put black pepper in there or sometimes a
little bit of honey I don't think
anything just raw dog in it he would
yeah he'd be watching sports drinking
I'd turn around and be in the kitchen
watching the game still just
uh anyone in your family ever own a PT
Cruiser no
any ATVs out there in The Killers
household no no it's mini bikes no nice
Suburban neighborhood okay you have a BB
gun as a kid no I have one now though at
my parents house yeah what kind are you
talking about rep did you go and buy it
it's a regular hand on a rifle yeah yeah
nice did you go and buy it uh I don't
know how we got it I have no idea how it
showed up and it's very exciting you
walk into the walls the little kids love
it
might as well be a bazooka to a little
kid yeah uh do you ever have a paintball
gun no okay Super Soaker yes yeah
yeah [__] hot [__] super soccers were
awesome the best yeah
um huh all right all right I mean he's
Towing in both worlds yeah a little bit
As Seen On TV products in the household
growing up or now no you never had a
Clapper a snuggie Chia Pets doggy yes no
Shamwell
yeah Okay add an eagle Snuggie I had a
[__] Snuggie I might have told it
here let me stop me if I did dude after
I quit West Point
and I I could you know quit and they
were playing army navy was in Philly
one of those games I was at Westchester
my sister was having a snuggy bar crawl
so I'm in a [__] Ninja Turtles nugget
the team goes to the bar that I'm at
after the game the kids that watched me
cry and quit
we're at the bar drinking after their
Army Navy game I was in a [__] Ninja
Turtles Snuggie what and they were like
yo it's Gillis dude what are you doing
here hey what's up guys you're like how
are you doing I was like pretty good I
was doing the combine now it was great
things are going well you definitely
didn't tell us that that's why it hurts
brutal that one's a tough memory you
didn't leave I would have ran away
again and I was just with like 10
lesbians
they all look like you yeah for real
I might have had a faux hawk
for sure
who won that they were kind of cool at
that point I think Navy won so hey [__]
those [__] yeah [__] those Army
losers anyway those guys probably all
into Iraq yeah
you guys are a bunch of Heroes they're
[__] losers
and my Ninja Turtle Snuggie uh uh are
there any carnival games you think
you're good at
the ring toss the basketball yeah I
think I suck at all
I think I suck at all I feel like I
thought you would have been like
prideful about like you [__] you got
to see no no yeah okay terrible who
babysat you as a kid uh neighborhood
people okay yeah but I had older sisters
they were six and seven years older sure
so they were older so they were watching
yeah that's not bad that's respectable I
do know how to tie a tie I presume no I
mean I can't I can't it's just very bad
I wore a clip-on in high school huh
gentlemen a lot of clip-ons and uh how
many suits do you own now
and how does it fit uh yeah fits now
good suit sharp suit good shoes for my
sister's wedding okay but name brands
gray I don't know what brand did you get
it like today's man or something Jose
Banks
yeah that's good it's a [__] Steve
Harvey it really is and now I gotta wear
it I wear it to funerals I wear it
everywhere yeah
what's the deal with girls today anyway
last time you had a massage
recent good yeah tell us it's nice on
the road yes uh uh I was in
I don't I don't remember where but yes
the whole time I was like yeah was it
like an appointment one or you popping
no it was a spa in the hotel ah yeah
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking I
thought I was gonna get whacked off the
whole time man that's every time I'm
just like am I gonna get jerked off
uh-huh and I'm nervous the whole time
yeah you're in a Hyatt and I laughed I
can't stop laughing every massage I get
I laughed the entire [__] time and I
had to tell it I was like is this normal
and she was like you're the only person
no you're actually it's like I've ever
done this yeah
it hurts hmm it hurts your body massages
yeah
they get in there [__] dude what's the
last time you got one a few weeks ago
couples massage me and him
I did him first
I like to see that I like to see you
treating yourself man he was trying to
get a [__]
yeah it starts off on his back again he
puts a towel over his face don't get
naked I don't get naked I leave my boxer
I go kind of almost weekly at this point
I got a bad back I leave the boxes on
every time you go weekly I try to hit
the road and [__] the flights yeah we'll
try though loosen up a little bit it's
good I like it also it's an old Asian
one she's like old and fat so it's like
not even on the table Yeah was there any
show as a kid that you watched as a
family like would you sit down and watch
Jeopardy no no I don't think anything
you have a TV in your room as a kid no
are you allowed to eat in your room no
really no okay I wasn't allowed to eat
in the living room really oh yeah that's
strict yeah are they strict about
everything or just that like in the
house just that yeah okay she was off in
the household no no no can't eat in the
living room but you're walking around
your [__] dirty shoes I didn't know
that was such a thing people get mad
every every episode of our podcast we're
wearing shoes in my apartment
a lot of comments are like take your
[__] shoes off really New York's a
little suburbs or New York is New York's
disgusting sure if you're taking the
subway and you're walking around and
[__] yeah yeah huh anyway would you ever
go to karaoke song
Werewolves of London
that's not bad it's an easy one that's
pretty good how about you
um I couldn't say I have a go-to I'd
probably do an original
it's got a guitar for the kids all right
pull out the tape you can sink but a
little bit yeah I bet he can he's good
he's a he's a good musician a little bit
I'd probably do Joe Cocker or something
like that yeah yeah I don't know what
that is
um goodbye With a Little Help from My
Friends oh nice yeah I'd probably hit
that's fun yeah something low something
nice where was the London's all right
though thanks man I've never done it and
I never will let me ask you this never
it's pretty fun I wanted it's like
dancing at a wedding I want to do
whatever you want you don't have to sing
No I just can't do I can't bring myself
to do it let's say you're at a
restaurant table next to you it's their
birthday the waiters come out and
they're singing Happy Birthday will you
start singing along no
will you ever tell anybody uh if I'm
[__] up yeah if I'm buzzed yeah
okay crazy yeah well you tell people uh
it's someone's birthday at the table
like will you tell the waiter so they
come over I have done that in the past
as a business
okay I respective it's a fun bit yeah
huh hmm have you or anyone in your
family ever skied in jeans
Spring Mountain Jack Frost I have winter
I didn't have shows of course yeah
that's a that's a PA Jersey instance
okay is it a drugstore or a pharmacy
I think drugstore okay we call it a
drugstore
we only had one we called it CVS
yeah will you fart in an Uber yeah will
you roll the window down
no it's a dead giveaway
the window down first hey man can you
roll the windows down
uh uh are all your bills on autopay yes
yeah it's smart yes
for a while they weren't for about 10
years they were just yeah I'm just
starting literally never now have
everything on you yeah oh my cell phone
still gets shut my mom pays my cell
phone bill family plan
yeah yeah very nice to send her the
money for it I forget always
um
what was I gonna say well you use the
venmo instant transfer someone Venom
owes you 100 bucks or 10 whatever do you
instantly transfer it or do you take the
two to three days yeah really you're
getting cash back
if you make a purchase but you get some
money from it I just got a credit card
first credit card ever yeah really yes
yeah we talked about it at the [__]
thing yeah I just got it oh yeah it's an
Amex now yeah we convinced them to get
the AMX no you guys we asked them like
what kind of credit card
six hundred dollars
what are you doing you idiot yeah I have
all my money in my debit card
I don't know I don't know money
oh man I don't know money at all I'm
sorry on that same tip will you send a
venmo request to somebody like if I owed
you 50 bucks no no classy gentleman but
10 years ago
four years ago sure yes yay of course
looking for that I did it yeah no money
it's my money dude yeah
yeah they're trying to drink well you
stack plates in a restaurant like but
when you're done with them when you put
the plates together no no okay
he just got mad who does that not a
[__] bus you want to do that I do it
sometimes yeah you stack the place yeah
stack the place make it easier oh you
know what yeah like a like an appetizer
plate a basket or something I'll give
you plates full meal plates from
somebody else that's done yeah that's
crazy
that's very weird okay uh it's coming up
I would say what are you doing
yeah at the table I'm still eating what
are you doing
what's the key situation how many keys
you got
uh three that's it yeah three but only
one is yeah I only use one what's the
attitude I have no idea what they're for
they're just on the link
I don't know what they are
do you check your mail
uh
uh no not really you probably have a
slot don't you yeah yeah all right
do something else
uh anyone in your family still have an
AOL email address hmm yeah probably
probably some uncles still yeah banging
with an ale yeah getting those old man
forward email changes
Obama's a man
thank you
cap you know what this is
adamandeve.com
knock knock who's there bonerville let's
go you ordered the butt plugs yes I did
right this way beep beep drop bags Adam
and Eve's a good time I'll tell you that
whether you're with a friend or you're
by yourself it doesn't matter do
yourself a favor get over to Adam and
Eve pick yourself up something what
could you get get a little Lube you get
a Tickler a whip a [__] ring nipple
clamps whatever whatever you want baby
it's a good time you're saving money
you're taking some broad out to dinner
just get something to go home and shove
it up yeah yeah what are we doing here
put your something in something or put
something in you that's the motto over
here baby send the kids to Grandma's and
spice up their sex life go to
adamandeve.com the number one adult toy
superstore yeah and don't forget the
condoms because we play it safe around
here uh you get it all at adamandeve.com
uh are you garbage listeners get a very
special offer for a limited time only go
to adamandeve.com and you'll get 50 off
just about any item select your one item
off at fifth select your one item at 50
off you'll also receive six free adult
DVDs
chantalizing free mystery just to get
things going huh something to play in
the background you know what I mean it's
a mood and you can always feel uh to top
it off they're they're even throwing in
free shipping on your entire order and
you look at that order and you'll always
feel secure because you'll always get a
90-day risk-free returns when you shop
at adamandeve.com shout out to them so
go to adamandeve.com use code garbage to
check out use code garbage at
adamandeve.com to save 50 off your first
item do it now back to the show back to
the show do you appreciate a lumberjack
breakfast what exactly is that that
would be like eggs bacon sausage comes
with pancakes or waffles I don't like
the pancakes and Waffle part yeah yeah I
did just have it at Waffle House and it
was pretty good Waffle House is a good
waffle you're not that much of a waffle
or pancake guy no French toast guy
they're Deli it's delicious but yeah
you're just not into it yeah I don't
like starting the day with [__] heavy I
could eat 10 pancakes sure I use sweets
guy not really yeah that's right this is
just alcohol and meat ain't nothing
wrong with it baby gout [__] I'll do it
do you have gout no I'm afraid to get
shot before it it has to come yeah how
do you take your eggs over easy I mean
respectable bacon crispy big eggs
benedict guy too whoa don't tell your
parents
Benedict look at you you guys make me
feel all right
classy guy yeah would you ever get that
when you were a kid no when did this
start up
that's new money [__] no I've been
having it when he moved up there when he
moved up there to New York actually yeah
probably those ham and cheese omelette
forever shout out to him and cheese
omelette I didn't have my first things
Benedict Was yeah probably six years ago
yeah it was the first time I had one and
I wasn't really sure what it was I
didn't know either yeah and now I'll now
took a chance will you when you're
getting in the shower get in through the
front of the shower or the back of the
back really yeah and you can enter the
water dude it's [__] psycho man well
you're entering the middle
you're entering the entire shower
wait you get in the water dude
crams into the toilet gets
hit my I stick my hand in and feel the
water and I get in I don't want to I
don't want to jump in You Gotta Creep in
you gotta let the feet do the testing
your legs do the testing and then you go
figure it out all right I'm aware that
that's the classier move I'm going to
give that uh do you put your pants on
and then socks or socks than pants
pants and socks probably yeah shirt
first
it goes underwear shirt let me last
thing I want to see is me in the mirror
oh that's bad naked bending down to put
[__] socks on so it goes on these
shirts pants socks yeah okay respect it
occasionally I accidentally do undies
pants then you're just walking around in
like jeans ah I don't know I don't even
have that confidence in front of my life
yeah it's terrible no way I closed the
door to get changed yeah I still hide my
flask of penis from my woman
oh yeah it is what it is
a couple acorns and a little Bush that's
it it's tough dude
can you see it from the front what do
you mean my noodle yeah a little bit
okay
what do you mean him or just anyone no
no his all right
could an onlooker see his penis
that's not that crazy I've seen his
stomach you can see the area
it doesn't it doesn't hang over I can't
see it it could be on my knee for all I
[__] know
somewhere down there
what about the deodorant are you putting
the deodorant on first and then the
shirt yeah
every time look at that I'm sure it
first what color deodorant are you using
white there you go ladies deodorant no I
do
Old Spice white oh that white oh yeah
that's like too creamy yeah oh really
it's like cream cheese for me yeah I
respect it what's in the house right now
as far as food snack wise is there
anything in there zero zero nothing's in
my house nothing yeah
any beers in the fridge no beers no
beers I don't drink at home I have the
same rules yeah that's why I know it's a
problem that's how I know it's not
really a rule either like I don't like
just sitting I'm not going to sit by
myself and get away although I've done
it and it's really great
it's getting [__] up by yourself
[__] the pandemic I would get just my
wife would go to bed at like 11 and I
would just sit up and get [__] I'd
bottle a wine beer whatever was there
yeah that was all right have you ever
shotgun to beer alone
oh [__]
I would say definitely I have no doubt
when was the last time you did a beer
bong
uh Rogan I did it oh that's right that's
right 20 beers this year
[Laughter]
I forgot about it what about sleeping
how many pillows are you using
as many as I can get dude okay you leave
it on your side
I try not to but yeah try to sleep on
your back yeah kind of pillow between
your legs when you sleep on your side I
like to yeah if I can I can reach one
yeah yeah it's so nice you got a fan
cooking while you're going come on
come on man sleeping silently is insane
that's how the thoughts get you yeah you
gotta drown those things do you have a
TV in there yeah you do you fall asleep
with this I don't watch it no really
yeah I never use it you just go in and
go to bed yeah he wasn't I listen to a
Book audiobook what kind of book we
talking Hitler okay
it's pretty good
let's see where I left off
oh that's the name of the book is Hitler
I have to compensate for his resignation
from the National Socialist Freedom
Movement if you know you could have got
an american guy
[Laughter]
in all of Germany
you're the toughest nerd I know
Jesus Christ you guys got to learn about
stuff
ah I gotta get back to being a nerd I
used to be I used to read a lot yeah
well you're a very uh you're a smart guy
intelligent guy smart guy you're very
you are well read you know a lot about
history yeah what was the s.a.t scores
remind us it was a 1170 I think it's
pretty solid fine would you get were you
dumb as [__]
wasn't it the guy who can't see his dick
no you told me this
you told me what was your SAT score
it was 11 40. I think his is like
astonishing it's three digits 13.50 no
you [__] liar what was it I got an
870.
I still got into college it's pretty
good and then failed out did you oh yeah
where'd you go Widener University yeah I
know what yeah had some boys play there
yeah yeah it's all right it's a good
time
it was a good time how was graduation
like
wasn't there
crazy
everybody doesn't we have people on we
ask them and they don't want to reveal
and I go no he got an 87.
loosens it up a little bit
you're among good people here uh have
you ever washed shoes in the washing
machine or the dishwasher washing
machine yeah
I didn't know you could do that yeah
they never come out just as well no they
get [__] destroyed
so many times
then they smell worse ah they get like
waterlogged and [__] yeah it's not good
you keeping the customer receipt no
never never hmm okay
I don't return things
never never now I mean the customer
receipt for like a restaurant or you're
closing on a tab at a bar let's put it
in somebody knows no why do you keep
that well I take it because they could
fill it out you have no proof somebody
put 500 tip down what and it closed my
back yeah yeah financially ruin me for
about three years dude I was driving I
remember driving I'd be like dude if I
get a flat tire it's over I'm bankrupt
yeah it's over yeah yeah of course
have you ever had breakfast in bed
I don't think
okay
have you ever bought a pair of Skechers
no it's coming
one of those sneakers that uh Sam
talent's always pushing Matt Matt wears
them mccusker yeah
oh yeah swears by him yeah yeah I
thought Sam was rocking the new balances
those the all like the dad shoes he
wasn't he found he found this brand he
was on the Nike monarchs the monarchs
that's what it was the Nike Monarch yeah
hmm it was good these are like shoes for
a guy who's one leg is shorter than the
other leg I got they got the platform on
it yeah can you play chess no really
yeah I can't I have no idea surprised
never tried I would have I would have
pegged you 100 really thanks what's your
favorite flavor of Gatorade
light blue he said the color it's trash
glaciers Glacier freeze that's my go-to
hung over I'll go dark blue I feel it
has more nutrients yeah it does you're
exactly all right this is 900 grams of
sugar
you need it anybody in the family with
an associate's degree
is that after bachelor's no that's
before but it was two years oh no I
don't think so
anyone in your family get married at the
courthouse
yeah
yeah did your boss go to school did he
go to college
yeah he went to Clarion really yeah nice
oh it's not great
that's a good school Clarion in this
[__] 70s oh fair enough I didn't
think of that yeah
uh uh anyone your family rep Ever
represent themselves in court no
so I was getting uh my friend got
arrested for we were I was driving we
were driving past a cop and he screamed
he was like [__] pig yeah they don't
like that and he caught us and he tried
to he pulled me out of the car he didn't
pull me out he made me come out of the
car and he was like what'd you say and I
was like I didn't set he was like who
did I was like I'm not gonna tell I was
like I can't snitch on myself ain't no
rat he was like well it came from your
side of the car and I was like yeah and
it wasn't me I do the math here come on
dude I'm not telling you but it wasn't
me
and then uh we went to court and he
brought you in for that Court dude what
what was the charge I'm obstructing he
was pulling someone over uh this is
[__] but it's like a trumped-up
charge it was crazy yeah and then the
middle of it my dad stood up said
something in the I guess he knew the
judge somehow I don't know [__]
Larry he goes he said something and the
judge like jokingly was like are you are
you his attorney and my dad goes no but
I did stay at a Holiday Inn Express last
night
went wild
it's unbelievable
all right you guys get out of here yeah
that's [__] convicted it wasn't me it
was like we were like his Witnesses did
he say bacon or whatever did he get
convicted I think so just had to pay a
fine or something yeah
was a cop there to testify yeah slow day
huh dork
you're always banking on the cop not the
show yeah my my brother represented
himself in court for a public uh public
drinking down in the shore and he was
just like I got nothing better to do I'm
[__] going and he was like proof
what's in my soul prove what was in my
Solo Cup you don't have any evidence he
was watching laws
your honor my client that's you what are
you talking about I think the Judge is
just like hey man like it was like I'm
making this up a thousand dollar ticket
or whatever he's like dude just pay 250
bucks and we can all leave yeah it's
like all right deal yeah
got out of it though nice what are you
thinking Kip
hmm I don't know uh let's see do you
ever have any subscribe to maximum
magazine FHM no but
um I think I was
I don't know why but I was bedridden it
was he like wisdom teeth or something
okay and my aunt gave me a maximum
magazine oh [__] and I [__] I
plastered that [__] I was coming on it
I whacked off onto it and would just
tear the page out
tear it up and throw it in the toilet
hit the toilet what
is going on I'm [__] on a magazine
man someone dude you had to call a
plumber at some point and he's like yeah
there's half a massive magazine in here
confetti
maximum see this all the time man yeah
your son of his wisdom teeth
off for three days up there this is
pipes full of Tara Reid dude oh man dude
I had the Desperate Housewives one and I
[__] cut them out put it on the wall
the whole night my mom walked in she's
like get these [__] Off the Wall
Terry Hatcher shout out to her
no at that point I had uh DVDs for sure
a DVD or two so you had pictures of the
that was an ABC show that was on like
eight o'clock I mean I wasn't jerking
off to the TV show it was their maximum
spread they were hot oh yeah I'd like to
see that yeah it was pretty good man Eva
Longoria yeah she was unbelievable
unbelievable huh all right
um
let's see ah if we went to your house
right now and asked for a water what are
we getting
we've got a Brita on the counter
Ed
why that why is that he left it out
for the last month
hydrates you better haven't touched it
it's good though okay
I don't I don't disagree it hydrates you
quicker they say is uh how new is the
filter in that Brita Shane um
it's moving slow
I don't know what's going on okay yeah
it's old yeah it's old yeah I mean I
need to go buy it probably never
replaced it probably not but that's all
right New York City yeah exactly any
magnets on the fridge
uh no
Pop-Tarts or Toaster Strudels pots not
even close did you get him as a kid uh
occasionally yeah but I would just plow
through just cry away yeah sure it's
more Pop-Tarts it was over yeah yeah I
was like that was candy that wasn't even
breakfast yeah that was crazy uh ever
write anything on the wall of a bathroom
or porta potty
no okay
any trophies currently display in your
apartment
I don't think okay
see if there's any out there if there's
not you're hitting the garage
2010 I won a
comedy competition okay okay New York PA
it's like a golden mic I think it's
actually down in damn you got a golden
mic yeah I mean it's put that on display
though I think it's your Tommy and
Chris's room that's pretty sweet yeah I
think it's in their apartment still
that's pretty sweet yeah I only got a
couple more here uh have you ever worn
shoes to the beach
no have you done a jello shot in the
last 365 days yes
uh tailgate a lot go to a lot of games
all right I'll give you that that's fun
I like it that's a good time my cousin
he's trash
you're not too classy yourself here's
socks and shoes holy [__] these are bees
are the sneakers on the beach
Beezer went to the beach with us he wore
like jean shorts or like yeah like he
was going to the mall jean shorts a
t-shirt hat sunglasses socks and shoes
he was just fully that's why she's like
button down that's crazy dude
anybody in your family ever claim to
have seen a UFO no okay hmm
pretty cool will you buzz the flight
attendant never good man will you send
food back at a restaurant never have we
asked to change a table
uh I try not to no never almost never
change hotel rooms no are you leaving
something for the cleaning lady and the
hotel yes if I have cash yes what are we
talking the 20. classic yeah good man
are you banned from any bars no
ever been thrown out of a restaurant
not since
like college okay okay yeah yeah that's
fair enough
um you open your eyes underwater in the
pool yes in the hospital you should see
me
no what do you mean why do you do that
see what's around
I can't do that I don't know what I'm
finding destroy your eyes
I've been doing it once I was a kid it
must be dark red coming out of that dude
you must look crazy wait what do you
mean why are you doing this
there's nothing to see
it's for The Rush man I like to live on
the edge yeah you like the pain
[__] ah man uh I mean I'm pretty good do
you wear any cologne no never never
the [__]
yeah the Clone with my Notre Dame
coaches Polo I'd go nice it actually has
that game more little English leather uh
what do you think Kim you know how to
use chopsticks
yeah kind of okay yeah okay yeah I can
like that
watch the luggage situation I've won I
gotta I gotta fix it though it's [__]
up yeah I gotta buy a new one okay it's
broken the zipper ripped off carry on
book bags
oh a school bag yeah I grew up saying
book bag my cousin said School everybody
says backpack yeah that's news that's
correct that's the [__] Tick Tock
kids yeah I don't like that it's either
a school bag or my book bag yeah people
make fun of you they go what are you
[__] eighth grade what else do you
want to call it my Satchel it is what it
is uh you currently have any two dollar
bills no but I would like them okay any
coin collections at the house or
anything
no okay I don't do anything
apparently you just sit around and do
jello shots I sit down
I mean um yeah I mean I'm good it gets
trash I don't know what to tell you
through and through
and through but a lot of a lot of
surprises I would say
yeah Spain but that's only going to get
you so far
I was actually stunned about the oysters
and the sushi I'll be honest with you I
like I don't like it doesn't like oil
the sushi yeah oysters are disgusting I
don't [__] right yeah you like them
love them little cocktail sauce Sublime
next time we're out we're out to dinner
I'll get you to try one all right try it
out I don't think I'm gonna like it a
little white wine I like wine you like
white wine yeah there you go anyone do
you know anything about wine
no idea yeah you ever ordered an
expensive bottle when you're out to
dinner uh I think I have but I don't
know I don't really I can't tell the
difference give me this one yeah your
point I go what's the best one and I
don't know best one well yeah I mean
which one of these is good okay I don't
know what I don't know why I don't know
steak I don't know wine I don't know
food yeah
man I do know Bud Lights though Bud
Lights uh-huh yeah they're trying to
take Bud Lights from us right now that's
a big it's a big to do I'm not worried
about it nah I'm chilling yeah
everybody stop drinking Bud Lights more
for me yeah that's what I say true all
right let's wrap it up hey guys that was
great yeah thanks everybody was it yeah
what are you talking about
everybody wanted to that was beautiful
yeah it was great the young when are we
getting [__] up again soon I hope yeah
I got I got [__] 40 Bud Lights right
behind me and a big buck on her machine
I do have nothing to do I'm done for the
day
stack of quarters you guys ever driving
Tesla I expanded one I've never driven I
just tried one did you try and you look
are you looking up no I'm not gonna buy
one of those you don't even have a car
do you no I don't you got rid of that
one car yeah I gave it to my sister yeah
that was like a Corolla it was a Chevy
Cruze dude oh I did have the Corolla
that thing is that was [__] up do you
want to get a car you want to get a new
car I don't need if if I live in New
York I don't anymore I don't really need
one yeah I have all my life how are you
getting to your parents what how do you
get to your parents uh I'll take the
train really yeah okay Harrisburg
there's a Harrisburg stop yeah yeah
that's true to that room out there
Labor Day yeah no no we did the we did
another room yeah no I featured for
someone at the comedy zone like five
years ago not bragging we did that we
did the other room on Labor Day
with Shaner yeah what's the other one
hmac
there's a bar on the left and then like
uh yeah that's 18 to the right yeah yeah
I used to book shows there yeah Shaner I
probably booked you guys on that
yeah yeah was there ever drama with that
no what are you talking about guys
thanks for tuning in
before we get kicked out
I have to leave the raven a few times
ladies and gentlemen Shane Gillis hey on
tour right now
yeah Matt and Shane's secret podcast
Gillian keeves check it out Amazon best
sketcho out there thanks man right it's
up on Amazon it's on Amazon very nice
anything else you want to folks out
there
[Laughter]
dude did you know I took O'Connor up
there the next day
yeah you took them upstairs again yeah
because I was with them later that night
we came back over to the house that
night and he was awesome he passed out
yeah while we were playing again
that kid's got a problem
all right all right buddy we love you
gang we love you we'll see you next week